[Musique]
bien sûr j'ai eu peur j'avais peur j'avais peur d'en
douter à nouveau mais une
chose dont je n'ai jamais douté c'est que je
crois que quelqu'un sinon nous sinon moi
quelqu'un gagnera quelqu'un sera là
mais le truc c'est que je pense  c'est le
début d'internet 1999
tout le monde a de bonnes chances qu'il
n'y ait pas d'expert à ce moment-là même jusqu'à
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'expert de demain
il n'y a qu'un expert d'hier personne ne
dirait que demain serait
comme ça donc c'est ce que je pense  nous
n'avons pas de système pour soutenir cela
comment je peux surmonter mes doutes et mes peurs
mais j'ai essayé d'être transparent envers mon équipe
lorsque vous faites des affaires ma règle est de ne jamais avoir
peur ne vous inquiétez jamais d'une compétition
ne vous inquiétez jamais de vous connaissez le  de
prix si tu t'inquiètes de la pression
tu t'inquiéteras d'une compétition si
ça t'inquiète ne sois pas stupide
sois un homme d'affaires et aujourd'hui la bonne
chose c'est que le monde entier s'inquiète
partout où les gens s'inquiètent pour les données
les gens s'inquiètent pour la vie privée les gens s'inquiètent
à propos de la sécurité, les gens s'inquiètent et
tout ce qui est normalement le meilleur signifie qu'une
grande opportunité se présente parce que vous savez que
vous ne pouvez pas arrêter cela l'heure d'Internet
arrive l'heure du mobile revient
les données arrivent vous ne pouvez pas vous arrêter ne vous inquiétez pas
avec la
seule chose que vous embrassez vous changez
vous-même  quand je salue les gens
salut les gens qui sont plus intelligents que moi et
je pense que les gens l'aiment pendant quatre cinq
ans plus tard, il peut être mon patron j'aime
travailler pour lui c'est le meilleur et deuxièmement
j'aime sa personnalité toujours la personne que vous
connaissez bien et  n'abandonnez pas facilement de
parler de si simple
je ne dis jamais bien je vais vous embaucher
et laissez-moi voir votre détermination quel
diplômé universitaire qui ne fait
rien pas
si important
ou l'important est les gens intelligents
jour intelligent  tu es tu aimes sa
personnalité et j'aime les gens qui
n'abandonnent jamais si je donnais des conseils aux
jeunes quand tu es diplômé de
quelque part tu cherches un emploi le premier
emploi est le plus important pas nécessaire
une entreprise qui a un nom vert toi
aurait dû trouver un bon patron
qui peut vous apprendre à être un être humain comment
faire les choses correctement
comment avez-vous pensé correctement et y êtes-vous resté
promettez-vous que je resterai là
pendant au moins trois ans ce qui
me tient éveillé la nuit dans  ce monde
rien je dors sur les cheveux eh bien oui je
suis tu t'habitueras à ça quand tu
traverseras la vie comme cette entreprise de mica comme
Ali Baba
les gens cherchent toujours le bon côté mais il y
a tellement de moments effrayants Juarez et puis
et tu dois surmonter  encore une fois encore une fois
maintenant je sais si je ne peux pas bien dormir
les problèmes dorment bien sachez que
quoi qu'il arrive